hey how's it going the other day i was
driving in my vehicle and this song came
on and i
instantly had this just reaction of just
wanting to dance there's so many songs
out there that probably do the same
thing for you guys i don't know what it
was about this freaking song i didn't
know what it was i just wanted to dance
who is this who is this oh my god gotta
find shazam so
pull into some back alley oh god she's
damn download he
hold my phone up i'm like okay finally
figure out what the song is called i'm
like yes this is my jam
then i download i get out of my car and
i start freaking just going
nuts
give me some of that
i mean just dancing in the street
dancing to my car
what is that song for you that makes you
just wanna
dance
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and make sure you follow me
all over the internet as i just seen
that's all peace
time to go dance
oh my god
this is my jam
oh god oh god
you know this is sturdy enough
so i'm outside now because i attempted
to start shooting this video in my hotel
room but it was so dark and it's also
rumored to be haunted